50 seconds of logos all great movies
start with blurry blurry something now
get ready for some reading also not sure
whether to send the film thinking the
audience needed up previously on these
rebooted Apes movies summary or the too
obvious capitalization and font changes
on the words rise and dawn
monkey killer I mean the rest of these
helmets at least try to say something
clever but this one just says monkey
killer at least go for a little
alliteration like monkey Mangler or
something surely the movie is a 93
percent Rotten Tomatoes rating but I'm
betting it has a 6 percent on the people
who get the bedtime for Bonzo reference
rating trader Apes or more commonly
known as traipse maybe it's the 4k
transfer talking but wholly ape this
opening confrontation is great problem
is it's the only actual ape versus human
war battle in this entire war movie
I got having someone yell reload as a
military truck but the guy with the
crossbow who has already reloaded this
weapon himself several times he's asking
for more arrows I don't get this at all
and yeah Traip shows up with more arrows
but I mean Jesus have you seen all the
explosions why is this dude on the
frontline still firing crossbow arrows
first one was for silence and
sneak-attack reasons but now he's just
needlessly wasting time on inefficient
weaponry colonel just gives a field
command to the first guy who radios him
about the captain being dead coming
Jesus way too many seconds of apes
getting out of Caesars way he's the
leader we get it we got it last movie
actually I do not starve this
the April did his dad Koba even after
you killed him last movie the humans
somehow still decided to believe lore
over Jason Clark's character and went
war with the Apes
really I guess I'm okay with these
movies ending an ape human warm but
blaming it all on Koba seems obtuse you
can make just as good a case that it's
Cesar's fault but then I'd have to spend
two weeks researching and writing and
pulling clips from various sources to
make an explainer video that most of you
wouldn't even watch in school you're
waiting this long to ask this they
brought you out here put you two by two
on horses and all that's left is to slap
those horses asses and you're just now
asking this why did they say winter
alone with the enemy I'm looking around
and I'm not seeing a shortage of monkey
power here why didn't I see that he
could not forgive what humans did
probably the same kind of blinders the
Academy uses to continue refusing you an
acting nomination for this mocap
brilliance
[Music]
shout out to the original movie via
eighth name is shout out eight prints
dewdrops dirt like it's unheard of
here's what we can live because there's
dirt and they're in the middle of a
goddamn mountain forest full of dirt
yeah they might have to move because the
humans know roughly where they live but
he went way far away grab some dirt and
thought it would somehow mean something
when did caesar's intelligence revert I
mean he's the smartest most tactical and
skilled character in all three movies
and he goes full horror trope dumb dumb
taking his sweet time inspecting
something he should know is danger when
quick action could have saved his family
even after catching a rope in the
waterfall Caesar still taking his time
ambling back toward his bedroom instead
of just screaming bloody murder at the
top of his lungs
also I am Caesar leader of the Apes and
distrustful of humans yet I live in a
huge-ass cave with an easily accessible
fourth wall and I keep no weapons of any
kind near my bed so I have to hunt for
them when danger arrives between the
flashlights and the green lasers I guess
the human soldiers were instructed to
announce their presence seconds or
minutes before their actual arrival no
one will be seated during the
snowpiercer portion of the movie
well no more monkeys jumping on that bed
I guess after all that the colonel fires
like a stormtrooper at Caesar because
there's still two hours of movie to go
of course and that's basically the only
reason he misses here dude unless Caesar
has gone full x8 and developed telepathy
I'm pretty sure he'd have to be looking
at you to understand the words that are
coming out of your hands hey let's all
assemble on the beach in the most
vulnerable manner possible
poor little Cornelius just lost his
mother and brother and it's now being
given by his father to a stranger if
ever the ape society needed to introduce
concepts like psychology and therapy
it's now Maurice somehow sits atop this
horse without uttering it ah Yeol you
thought you were gonna leave on a quest
without your bro is joining you when we
to have said bros right up on you
unexpectedly for a group hug moment
cliche I suppose I could give the movie
credit for not having them stopped by
the coke truck and actually pop some
tabs but come on this coke truck being
out in the middle of the forest is about
as blatant product placement as you can
get in this movie god damn the mocap
work by the actor Karen Carnival the CGI
by the visual effects artists the
writing of the scene it all results in
one of the most tender moments in any
movie this year I'm taking us in off for
a lovable old Maurice we cannot take her
Maurice and yet you do nobody has time
for this even though it's just the
eighth variation of the saying you won't
do something only to turn around and do
it right away cliche what if that monkey
just signed to Caesar as he's using
binoculars is he reading the subtitles
with those things
wait these three just slipped in here
without being seen that was a pretty
busy and active camp and did they leave
a little girl tied to a tree or
something
wife are dead
Andy freaking circus so we were they not
sitting around the fire was part of this
dream and part real was it all a dream
whatever happened a wavy lines and wind
chimes oh I know when the hell someone
is dreaming look this shot is actually
gorgeous but these Apes are following
way too closely a military convoy is
going to spot them following so closely
even if only by accident I feel bad for
her
this little girl must think life is
up she's had to see at least four
dead human bodies in the last 24 hours
she can't talk apes have kidnapped her
and taken her in a snowy hellscape does
she think this is normal like everyone
goes through this like everyone sees
Nixon before they die
she's mute but not deaf right okay I was
gonna let it slide when giant Luka and
has lately 400 pounds didn't seem to
bother this force at all but now you
throw on another 200 pounds up there
there is no way that horse is galloping
that easily and horse is being abused
this is all leading to an eventual
planet of the Stallions trilogy isn't it
that was bad ape this much better a
rider than these apes that have been
riding for a decade or more mostly for
military purposes so bad ape is slick
enough to sneak up without being heard a
good enough rider to outpace Caesar and
his most trusted friend soldiers but
dumb enough to just leave stupid ass
footprints leading to his own
whereabouts he paints this character
with whatever brush it needs in the
moment I was just sitting here hoping
they would add some primate prep balls
about an hour into this intense war
drama that very quickly forgot how to
war come on newbie I mean I get mood and
such but there's enough ape traveling
montages in this movie that it might as
well have been called horseback riding
for the Planet of the Apes hey how many
eight crucifixion scarecrows do you
think we need to make our point like
five I hope you don't come to regret
sparing his life he's quite a good shot
obvious foreshadowing is obvious
they know not what they do also Caesar
left the group to try and find the main
human Colonel and end the war early
they're acting like he was in cahoots
and knew that could captured how much
could set Colonel had tortured them to
make them forget all the years the
leadership and protection Caesar has
provided and just blackballing
okay I forgave the opening speech about
the opposing generals that literally had
him saying Custer and Sitting Bull but
now that we're going with these shapes
his head with a knife trope I have to
send this cliche villain who's making
these decisions the director or Harrison
I swear for the next 30 minutes of the
movie they just decided to do a
shot-for-shot remake of animated film
The Prince of Egypt that's the sound of
the Apes working on the chain gang as
Caesars in prison defiance inspires
these huge rock carrying Apes to throw
down and defy the man I'm just not
realizing this movie's biggest problem
basically the last castle with apes in
the snow if you've seen the last castle
that's a mic drop if you haven't well
Chris is an extra in it because they
shot it here in Nashville so I'd still
encourage you to watch it but still it's
a not too original prison revolt movie
that this eight movie is starting to
massively resemble also tacking onto the
previous in a bit
rise work because there'd never been
anything quite like it a real world
based sci-fi film about genetically
enhanced apes gone wrong dawn worked
because there'd never been anything like
it real world based sci-fi film about
two species friction as their planetary
dominance shifts from one to the other
war works I guess but it's like a lot of
things it's part Great Escape part Cool
Hand Luke part Ten Commandments part
Hogan's Heroes part Apocalypse Now part
Dirty Dozen it's just not nearly as
original as its two predecessors by
virtue of all the movies it steals from
torture scene guest directed by Mel
Gibson no late did not say this and she
certainly can't sign it with that
Boulder in their arms dangit movie
subtitles are not magic after like 24
hours or more the rest of Caesar's
private spy party finally goes looking
for what kind of wall are they
building they're looking huge rocks up
ramps made of wood and I mean Jesus the
army that attacks this joint later has
helicopters and missiles and bombs and
so all this quarry work for the Apes
seems like window dressing in case the
Jesus parallels weren't strong enough
for you to get it
ww CDR
movie wants to be all previous war
movies in one so here's your requisite
Vietnam era soundtrack entry need wall
you need a wall built of rocks and
Long's and no apparent bonding agent I
mean dude you've got easily exploitable
gas tanks behind that wall you meet a
lot of things but you do not need that
flimsy house wall you're much stronger
than we are
Jeff exposition here takes a full four
minutes to tell us about this virus's
unfortunate mutation and its personal
consequences sure there's a bit of
character work there but anytime someone
has time to fully cook and eat a meal
while expositor I'm guessing you could
tighten that up no matter what you say
you'd eventually replace us that's the
law of nature then why is this movie two
hours and 20 minutes long I realized
that I would have to sacrifice my only
son
so that humanity could be saved what are
you three sixteen it will be a planet of
apes roll bananas no no bad ape
accidentally himself into a secret
underground entrance to the camp so the
colonel agreed to Caesars demand that
decided to feed the Apes fine but he's
feeding them raw grain wheat germ
flaxseed the hell does he think apes eat
and worse than that
he just got a warehouse full of this
green lying around doing nobody any good
where do you get all that
this is cornmeal like a commodity and
this apocalyptic future he's still alive
in the morning so you don't care if he
lives or dies
you keep going back and forth on this
it's starting to piss me off are you
breaking down their leader so they break
down or are you just in with their
leader not giving what they do in
response when the scene worked better if
it were more recent stead of Caesar
Maurice is the one that gave her the
doll earlier and it would make nice
symmetry as the booty presents it it's
like hey Caesar remember that doll where
he escaped me back when you weren't even
in the room to witness it well it
happened and this reciprocation is
caused enough to motivate you and I
think so how exactly did supernova get
in here and do all this without being
seen most military groups have some sort
of scouts or security it's not like
she's even hiding also he's their leader
for Jim's sake there's no guard on the
most important primate in the camp oh
where did these guys come from
we saw the guards coming in from behind
the trucks but where these guys been the
whole time how did they not see anything
before now is it just me or is woody all
the sudden rain proof I don't see a
single drop hitting his glasses it's
jacket or his beautiful hit
is there an unpromising is he a rain god
does he bathing ringing axe
sorry on the cheese no movie again adds
character with the same name from the
original Apes movie in a desperate
attempt to both curry nostalgic favor
and confuse the hell out of anyone
trying to figure out how they could
actually be the same person see bad ape
is the physical embodiment of the you
better come take a look at this cliche
[Music]
this movie is not without its charm and
even my cold heart is willing to remove
us soon for that exchange he doesn't
notice this sheesh
how many years of acting classes did
this water take to get this good at
dramatic timing so let's go over this
primate plan shall we first fling poo
with accuracy and timing enough to hit a
card 60 feet up at the exact right
moment ii hope that the guard takes it
personally enough that rather than clean
it off he comes down and opens the
freaking pen to confront his attacker
third throw more poop in the hopes that
instead of running after the culprit he
will stand still above a pre-designated
hole long enough with both legs situated
apart perfectly to be pulled underground
and forth hope that no one hears him
yell before you knock him out with your
meaty monkey paws what could go wrong
also how'd they even time this maybe
they knew it was there through
vibrations and sound but that's a huge
leap awesome 8 moment ruined by logic
which could serve as a tagline for this
movie actually
again keys are not there's no way Caesar
would have been left unguarded in a way
that no one saw him unlock his own pen
makuu militia is about as observant as a
sign light concussion spotter and an NFL
game somewhere along the line this movie
turned into a serious version of chicken
run which itself was a play on Stalag 17
my point is that other than the ape
angle this is nothing new help
Maggie organize a daycare breakout just
like this on The Simpsons like 20 years
ago one hour and 52 minutes later in
this movie with the word war and the
title finally decides to war again and
of course it takes place primarily in
the background as if awakening from a
dream one lone soldier realizes how
those round things embedded in his face
are meant to be used and somehow focuses
them enough to notice that where before
there were hundreds of captives now
there are not well done lone human well
done indeed such a sad tragic end to
this man's love affair with his Bo Peep
doll oh sorry wrong woody wait how are
there any Apes left still crossing the
battlefield certainly there was plenty
of time while Caesar was away on his
suicide mission to find hiding spots or
clear the area
as if convenient gas leak isn't
convenient enough how is it that emits
bullets grenades rocket launchers and
crashing copters this thing hasn't
ignited already oh I guess after being
the only soldier here to notice the Apes
were missing back when this battle
started this asshole just hid inside the
camp waiting for his chance to kill the
ape leader he somehow knew would be
sneaking around here at some point what
in that chain reaction if this base was
this ready to go there's no way that
battle lasted past the first missile I
would call out the sudden Avalanche as a
typical ex MOC in a moment except for
one thing it serves no purpose why do
all the humans have to die Caesar wasn't
really in danger until he stood up to
see it and we all know the human race is
headed towards their demise anyway so
des is sex in up to you just like Moses
Caesar was prohibited from entering the
promised land mostly because of his
selfish behavior during the journey
thankfully he had already given the Apes
a few of their own Ten Commandments to
live by such as a pod kill ape Apes
together strong and thou shalt not stay
behind during rescue from a human
military compound for personal revenge
reasons lest you receive a mortal flesh
loot are we supposed to believe this is
from the arrow wound before the
Avalanche how long is this traveling
circus in his circus monkeys been
looking for a place to live I'm not
saying you couldn't die from the
injuries I'm just saying it probably
should have happened sooner son we'll
know Maurice knows this many spoken
words why isn't he talking more I mean I
don't expect him to be a chatterbox or
anything but there are plenty of times
when a few words could have gone a long
way
sorry to spoil the moment here but apes
don't cry not even when they're gunning
for an Academy Award need that wall
[Music]
what have I done what you see
brother's got a crazy old Maurice
[Music]
time to nut up or shut up string them up
donkey that'll do donkey that'll do